das ist es ist übrigens Alvaro der Name
weil viele sagen Alvaro
also ich kenne das okay also wie sagt
man
[Musik]
also wie reinkommen von da ja du kommst
mal
ganz genau
2,5 Milliarden Leute oder Streams hat er
für seine Musik das finde ich sowas von
toll
über 2,4 Milliarden
erfolgreichen Menschen habe ich hier
noch nie auf meinem Kanal nein aber ich
hoffe Erfolg muss man nicht nur durch
Stream sondern auch durch weißt Du
herzlich cocktailability ein Stahl Glas
ich habe sehr lange keine Cocktails
gemacht hast du noch andere Talente nee
ich habe dich gegoogelt natürlich ich
wollte wissen wer ist der Mann hinter
der Musik ja also erstmal bist du ein
Barcelona geboren 1991 und dann ganz
interessieren
also ich bin zur Schule gegangen aber
ich bin mit meiner Familie dahin gezogen
deutsche Schule gegangen in Tokio auch
noch deutsche Schuljahr krass und kam es
aus Barcelona deswegen spreche ich
Deutsch sozusagen mein Vater ist ja auch
Deutsch aber ich bin auf die deutsche
Schule gegangen in Barcelona sogar
deutsche Kindergarten sogar auch welche
Sprache sprichst du am besten Spanisch
ich dachte ich auch nicht die Wikipedia
Seite einfach ausgedrückt ich liebe es
ich liebe es wie kann
das wo noch aber du sprichst
sogar Ente in Italien
[Musik]
sind groß
in Deutschland
eine Stunde Wald
verflasche ich habe einen Casting für
beide Sprachen gemacht
von mir sehr erfolgreicher Musik auch
und der hatte natürlich die
Originalversion gemacht auf Spanisch
weil der Film ja in Kolumbien handelt
und erst sehr perfekt ich erzähle mal
von Anfang an wie das war ja ich habe
mein erstes Mal rausgebracht der
erfolgreich war weil da war ich auch
sehr viele Songs ausgemacht erfolgreich
waren
[Musik]
der kam dann raus 2015 steht irgendwo
hier auch drauf glaube in Italien
Veröffentlichung stieg dort innerhalb
von zwei Wochen auf Platz eins genau um
fünf auf Platten es war verrückt man
Instagram war nur italienische messages
viele haben öfters das gleiche
geschrieben bei Nomen will oder sowas
das war sowieso oder was heißt denn das
ist irgendwie Uhrzeit irgendwie komisch
da habe ich das alles auf translator
reingesetzt und im Fernsehen da habe ich
mir dann meine Antwort auch vorbereitet
damit ich den Leuten dann antworte auf
Instagram und ich habe sehr viel ja
wirklich allen geantworte so habe ich
meine college degree in Italienisch dann
ab 1 professionell genau
und dann bin ich dann nach Italien und
habe dann die ersten Interviews gemacht
und dann habe ich gemerkt dass viele ich
dachte erstmal okay italienisch auf
Spanisch dann können sie machen aber ich
hatte gemerkt dass sie keinen Spanisch
gesprochen haben und genauso wie ich
mich italienisch bekommen habe oder
Englisch auch nicht und dann dachte ich
krass ich hoffe ich hatte Angst dass ich
sage die nicht wirklich aufschreiben
konnten auf die Interviews weil sie
nicht so richtig verstehen was ich
antworte auf Englisch ich muss jetzt
Italienisch sprechen damit ich den
wirklich meine Message rüberbringen kann
und dann
kam dann halt mir so ein paar Leuten
dort und wie ist es halt ist Spanisch
nicht so weit weg voneinander und ich
war sehr oft in Italien also dann
irgendwann lernt man das Alter
reingezogen italienisch
auf meinem Kanal ich habe leider deine
Wikipedia-Seite nicht mitgebracht aber
richtig lustig gewesen wir haben vorhin
geschafft ich habe keine
willkommen zu einer fant
astischen drei Cocktails
die Uni kannst du das einfach auf
Spanisch sagen also das Cocktail Schuhe
genau
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
weil ich gerade ich habe morgen eine
Show und ich trinke kein Alkohol bevor
ich spiele deswegen können wir so machen
wollen wir so machen du machst Alkohol
volle Cocktails und ich mache
alkoholfrei Cocktails ich mache so
richtig viel ja und ich dann dafür sehr
wenig oder nichts
auch eine Alternative gibt sehr gut wir
müssen jetzt erstmal einkaufen gehen
damit wir unsere Zutaten haben hast du
schon so eine Idee gehst du schon dann
so eine Richtung Inspiration gesammelt
die letzten Tage
ich bin in verschiedene Basen Berlin
reingegangen
hast
[Musik]
sie ist perfekt
dass du da irgendwie gerade am Song
möchtest du zuerst deine zu mir bitte
genau
[Musik]
Aperitivo Rosato
und Dekoration
also ich habe Wassermelone das ist
erstmal ein Basic gegen für Sommer weil
Wassermelone
meiner Schwester meine Schwester die
kann nur Wassermelone Essen im Sommer
und davon sicher ernähren dann habe ich
Erdbeeren auch mitgenommen gleiche Farbe
andere
[Musik]
dann habe ich super viel Basilikum
geholt weil es keine Minze gab nicht was
sie bekommen klar dann habe ich ähm
Maracuja Passionsfrucht du machst auch
Cocktails für das ganze Team hier
natürlich alleine hier und dann äh
Limetten weil wir in Berlin sind so ein
bisschen Rhabarber und dann denke hier
ist ja immer so viel rhabarberdrinks und
so und es ist die gleiche Farbe wie das
hier Wasser ich bin ganz oben
monochromen Trip verschiedene Texturen
gleiche Farbe Bluter weil es irgendwie
Standard ist oder immer und dann habe
ich noch gedacht weil die so geil
aussieht und dann habe ich gedacht
für die Leute die so ein bisschen weil
das ist alkoholfrei bei mir und dann
vielleicht so ein Ingwer shot für die
für die die Tafeln für den Spice aber es
sind irgendwas schon Granatapfel
ähnliche Farbe
weil ich habe gedacht irgendwie bei dir
fehlen noch was dazu
ja jetzt kommt noch mögen die durch
Spiele beginnen auf Spanisch ja
noch größere Messer
okay krass
[Musik]
ein bisschen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
nicht so gut verkaufen
sie du hast viel Talente in diesem
Bereich hast du das gelernt oder
gebracht Kochen Teil der Kultur deswegen
wenn du nicht kochen kannst dann bist du
unglücklich in Spanien ist immer Momente
[Applaus]
das war schon sehr talentiert ich habe
es
fasziniert weil ich habe am Anfang nicht
verstanden wieso leute das ist oder was
ist mit einem macht ich habe es nicht
verstanden ich kannte Leute die die so
richtig entdeckt waren wieso spürt ja so
krasse Sachen bei ist immer und ich habe
nichts
gespürtig ist und leise so ein Thema
Moment das ist bei Sahne auch immer ich
schlag die so lange und dann ist das
dieser eine Moment den man verpasst dass
man Butter macht perfekt
in Spanien oder so
ja versuchen zu pendeln aber ich finde
immer länger hier in Berlin auch durch
the voice Kids und so gerade bei dem
Prob
en das ist ja auch noch dann bist du
auch noch im Fernsehen ja also das ist
auch Fernsehen oder was wir machen heute
naja
mein Leben wo ich bin hängt wirklich
immer von meiner Arbeit ab ein bisschen
das ist halt schwierig zu planen weil du
halt einfach manchmal hast du mehr
Festivals in einem Land manchmal mehr in
einem anderen Land und das ja oh Gott
wow
unfassbar es ist
egal ich habe halt meine ganzen Freundin
sein kann
das machen alle Freunde von mir
einfach
bin weil so viele Leute mich so nennen
lässt die letzte Variante darf ich dir
sagen
oder wie man auf
amerikanische Hits
[Musik]
gemerkt gibt nur die Frau oh oh mein
Gott
[Musik]
gefunden nein ich wusste das gar nicht
gemerkt ich habe es nicht gesehen
wurde inspiriert von diesem Ort das
heißt und der Ort ist in diesem Süden
von Valentia und dort das wurde sein von
einem ganz Architekten natürlich
weltweit der hat auch in der Nähe von
meiner Schule in der deutschen Schule
hat auch ein Gebäude sein das war
ähnlich aus aber nicht so cool wie das
hier aber sind wirklich Leute okay mein
nächstes Thema jetzt Erdbeeren wo ist es
hier
[Musik]
in echtem Leben auch hallo heute ist
Sonntag der 18 Juli
18 bin ich noch ein bisschen so am
Proben und dann vorbereiten also heute
meine und dann habe ich die ersten Shows
ab dem 30 Juli vor der Tür mein trinkt
man nach der Tür
[Musik]
krass
wir gehen auf die Piste
[Gelächter]
was verbindest du im Sommer eigentlich
bestimmtes Parfum und Sonnencreme sobald
ich das erste Mal ja das ist jetzt guck
mal das sieht sogar krass aus aber ich
weiß nicht wie schmecken wird Basilikum
Maracuja oh oh
die very amazing wie gut sprichst du
Englisch kannst du englisch sprechen
wenn du sagst dass du Englisch
geschrieben hast du lustig
einfach
nur gut welche Küche ist die beste meine
Küche ja ich finde die spanische
italienische und japanische wenn ich
drei auswählen kann
also ich finde die beste Küche ist ich
finde wirklich die ähm ich bin nicht
Multitasking meine lieblingsküche ist
die spanische lass mal kurz probieren
was passiert
nicht so geil
mit Maracuja
Basel experimentiert
weiß man noch nicht wo die Grenzen sind
das
lebensexperimentiert weiß man noch nicht
die Grenzen sind
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
bitte sag ich liebe dich in allen
Sprachen aber immer mit dem Vanessa
hinterher bitte für privaten
dann Wassermelone
fantastisch dann Erdbeersaft
ein bisschen so dass ihr denkt jetzt
reicht und dann am Ende noch wie gesagt
das ist das Cocktail alles rote Farbe
schöne Geschmäcker und das ist sehr
Ingwer shot mit Granatapfel
also denkt das ist so wie Vodka jetzt
muss man so machen oh macht mir so viel
Angst
muss da rein fühlen müssen und dann den
Deckel drauf ne also kein Problem
ja ja meine ingredience
so machen
[Applaus]
wir dann ganz stylisch oh Gott das ist
echt krass das ist
gut so ganz professionell
[Musik]
kommt jetzt hier das Topping oben drauf
ich wusste es nein das ist ein Boot das
wird die ah nein das ist mein Cocktail
heißt
Basilikum Boot guck mal wow krass
eine Basilikum wurde überleben würde
irgendwas mit der Türkei zu tun kannst
du Türkisch
[Gelächter]
das ist ein extra Punkt
also ich habe jetzt die Sachen wirklich
ich dachte wir hätten irgendwie mehr
Zeit das ist Basilikum Maracuja das kann
sein
geil wow also was so also es ist nicht
stimmt es ist nicht schrecklich wie
Punkte
gefallen du stellst jetzt erstmal dein
Cocktail vor hallo
und genauso wie meine Single ist es
jetzt auch mit verschiedenen Rottönen
gemacht worden mit einem klecksgrün und
das ist jetzt besteht aus Wassermelone
aus Erdbeere und Saft also selber
gemacht alles natürlich und Granatapfel
Ingwer shot weißer goldfrei ist weil ich
natürlich morgen eine Show habe und für
alle wieder draußen die auch keiner Gold
trinken wollen könnt ihr auch natürlich
Spaß haben mit diesem Getränk wie viel
Spaß wenn wir jetzt rausfinden bitte
trinken sehen
auf jeden Fall nicht brennen doch
genau
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ist halt sehr viel Wassermelone sehr
dominante was nun aber es soll ja auch
Wasser mit mega mega geil
die deutsche Version machen wir jetzt
mal weggehen
pass auf wie der heißt ich habe den
Alvaro Soler
meiner ist der Alvaro Soler
glaube
Orangen aus Spanien Sahne aus
Deutschland
Ramazzotti aus Italien
vielen Dank danke
alles für mich stark es ist sehr sehr
sauer also Zitrus der cydrisch
es schmeckt nach Orangenschale oder hast
du benutzt
italienische Dinge gewesen
[Musik]
auf jeden Fall zum Glück machen wir
keine professionellen Cocktails
drin Melone zurück in der Evolution
zurückgestuft deswegen
t gut
aber probieren genau
[Gelächter]
online schönen Sommer macht man das
Radio an
mein Freund hier ist oft zu hören
wo bist du denn lieber ja
auf tiktok ist
egal
mit deiner Kochshow ja also ich muss
jetzt noch meine neue Staffel machen
also das habe ich letztes Jahr gemacht
und jetzt guck ich ob ich dieses Jahr
noch eine mache
ein paar Motivation von euch habe ich es
machen soll oder nicht
machen bei 300 Kommentaren macht er
jetzt
dabei ist 5000 Kommentaren
hier bei Youtube kann man auch
kommentieren
Fernsehen auf Youtube dann kommt Youtube
tschüss dann viel Spaß bei der Natur
danke Dir sehr schön danke
[Musik]